Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
I don't make it much of a secret,
but I get quite frustrated
when young people we work with
don't make the most of the opportunities
that they're provided.
So, just to give you some context,
we provide, on our website,
there's a plethora of opportunities
from some of the biggest organizations
in the country,
and you'll just get sometimes
a lethargic response from young people,
and I'm just like,
"God, like, do you know how amazing this is
to just have it served to you on a plate,
and you're kind of like, hmmmm?"
That frustrates me quite a lot,
and I have to,
I have to kind of keep that undercover.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.